le déconfinement donc se profiler c'est
le tourisme qui redécolle peu à peu
c'était le cas pendant ce long week-end
de l'ascension une clientèle française
que l'on retrouve notamment dans les
campings à l'arrivée des beaux jours à
nazelles négron les gérants veulent t'y
voir le présage d'une saison réussie à
lui cache pas la météo est encore
incertaine et pourtant déjà les campings
se remplissent à peine des confiné à
lycée marceau ont ressenti le besoin de
prendre l'air programme est d'euros
maximum se promener se balader et puis
voilà juste profiter aux week-ends
camping on a décidé comme ça sur un coup
de tête un peu de partir on est lillois
et on s'est dit on va visiter la tour n
une petite pause pour avoir un air de
vacances
comme lui ils sont une soixantaine à
occuper ce camping de nazelles négron ce
week end
de quoi donner l'espoir d'une bonne
saison touristique malgré le contexte
économique
moi je suis assez confiant et positif en
général après les réservations sont pour
l'instant son corps assez modeste l'an
dernier malgré le coc vide on a quand
même réussi à fuir une saison tout à
fait correcte même s'il ya eu des
inquiétudes un peu en début de saison
c'était sa part c'est pas très très bien
mais après après les gens sont venus
pour cette ville d'environ 3500
habitants le camping est un atout
primordial
véritable vitrine il brasse une grande
partie des touristes venus visiter les
châteaux ou parcourir la loire à vélo un
camping municipal ça représente un
aspect bien évidemment est avant tout
économique
le camping permet à la commune d'être
connu et surtout de faire fonctionner
nos commerces puisqu'on a des commerces
de proximité
à côté de ce camping et sa troupe permet
de mettre en avant la commune par
l'intermédiaire du contenu l'objectif
désormais est de se renouveler
habitat insolite stage de fauconnerie ou
encore dégustation de vins tout est bon
pour séduire les habitants éphémère de
nazelles négron